welcome
everyone to yet another topic on j unit
now in this one we are going to talk
about what exactly is in junit
uh tool all about and how we can do
various kind of
test implementations with the help of
junit now in this one specifically we
are going to talk about like
junit in java now let's talk about what
exactly is the junit tool all about like
what are the different things we can
implement with the help of this tool
here
so junit is basically a kind of unit
testing framework which is there for the
java
so it's kind of a default offering for
the java programming language that we
can use the junit
for the unit testing framework for
performing the unit testing
now the main benefit of the junit is
like it's
using the same syntax like a java
programming language
so it makes it very easy for a java
developer to write and execute the test
cases
so most of the times when the developers
are going to work on the java
programming languages
so they prefer that junit as a default
unit testing framework for them because
they get the language advantage they get
the easily integrations and the eclipse
so those benefits helps the developers
to decide junit
specifically for writing the test cases
and running the test cases there
now whenever these test cases are
actually being executed whenever you add
up a new piece of source code
so all the unit test cases will be
executed will be again executed there
every time when you run a new belt so
all the unit test cases gets executed
but you also need to take care that if
you are adding up a new functionalities
you also have to add the corresponding
test cases to that
so increasing more and more code will uh
will be done by the developers but at
the same time
you have to sync or you have to keep
your test cases up to date
also and as a part of every build each
and every test cases will be re-executed
every time you're doing the build five
times
six times a day every time the all unit
test cases will be executed over there
and the response will be given back
right now let's talk about what exactly
is the unit testing
now unit testing refers to the testing
of these small small modules or the
small piece of
chunks or the codes here now it's
basically used to
have the early identification of the
defects and the bugs because
you cannot simply rely on the qa team to
perform the testing
and then provide the feedback whereas on
the uh with the help
of this unit testing framework we can
immediately get the
feedback right away once we are running
the test cases
immediately we will be able to know like
these are the different test cases which
we have
got over here now the developers don't
even have to
spend more time on fixing the bugs and
issues because
these test cases will help them with the
easy and the fast feedback
so according to that they can fix the
bugs and they can take the decision
whether the
source code is working fine as expected
or there is any kind of
issues as such present with this one so
unit test casing is something which
is very important from the developer's
perspective also because it helps the
developers to understand that they
whether they have written a successful
code
or if there is any kind of scope of
issues or bugs over here
also it uh the successful unit test
cases uh
increases the overall confidence of the
developers because it uh
increases the overall uh performance and
the quality of the product also
so by having the successful executions
of the unit test cases
developers can understand that yes the
source code is working fine as expected
and there is no scope of bugs or any
issues as such with this source code
here
so that's the main benefit which we get
with unit testing that with this
fast feedback channel we will be able to
take
uh the decisions whether the source code
is ready for the production environment
deployment or not so that's a main
benefit
which we get with the unit testing here
now of course this can be done in two
ways manual testing and automatic
testing
now in case of manual testing you have
to do this thing manually
within a manual tester or a manual
testing approach
and in this one you will not be
depending on any kind of automated tool
which can be scheduled or which can be
executed in non-interactive manner on
the other hand automatic test case is
something which
uh is used to be executed using the
tool and uh it is something which is
being done so that you will be able to
get
the complete automation there is no
manual efforts which is required as such
you are going to have like complete uh
deployment and automations being done
as such in this case so automated
testing is something in which you will
be giving more focus on the automated
automation tools
you may be having one or a couple of
tools which using which you can write
the
automated test cases and you can perform
the complete automation
in case of manual testing it's quite a
you know less reliable because
you are dependent on the uh a particular
tester
which can ha perform the testing uh
according to his
efforts and it's quite a time consuming
also because you can only run the test
cases for
probably eight to nine hours per a day
whereas on the other hand the automated
test case is something which is uh
quite reliable because it does not
depends on a human so so requirements so
it can be done like 24 cross 7 so
anytime you can run those
test cases and that's the reason why
these test cases are quite faster
as compared to any other manual testing
approach here
so junit test cases and the automated
test cases
really helps the developers and the qa
professionals to test the
source code much faster as compared to
the manual testing
chair unit testing in the java like how
we can pretty much configure the test
cases in junit for a programming
language called java
and how we can get along or get execute
those things so now we are going to see
like how exactly we can
you know go for the um execution of some
java files onto our command line and how
we can
uh using the command line run some
execution of the test cases
typically we do it from the eclipse but
uh from the command line also we are
going to see like how
exactly uh you know we are performing
the setup and the executions over here
now what we really need to do is like we
need to see like how we can proceed
further with the execution so i'm going
to open this
uh particular java file over here so to
get a better understanding here
so i'm going to use the uh oj dot unit
junit uh
class over here in this case so we are
having a couple of imports
these are the standard imports so you
can do like orj.jstar also if you don't
want to go for the specific
imports here now here we are going to
create a test unit
as an uh sample class and in this one we
got the
void main over here which is the main
portion of any kind of class
here the only thing which we got over
here is that we have created a test
method over here called test print uh
message
so we are assigning a value called
message a variable over here as in
simply learn
now what happens like we will be able to
uh like you know do the assert equals
over here
that if the value of message is like
simply learn
so it will be able to help us with the
proper
output and uh there will be no errors as
such over here
so everything will be smooth and that's
what we are trying to execute over here
in this case
and we are running into the null void
that these are the test cases we want to
run or we want to execute over here
now all we need to do is we need to
compile this one we
really need to compile this k test cases
over here
this file and then we have to run that
one so for that let me open the command
prompt
so now in this case we will be using the
java c command prompt here and we will
be copying the
j unit into the class path so that we
will not be able to get any kind of
class not found issues over here so test
unit junit.java we are going to run so
if there is no
exceptions as such we will be able to
get no errors here
now i'm going to run the particular
class file with the help of java command
because java c is to
convert the dot java file to the dot
class file the compile format and then
in order to run the dot class file we
have to go for the
java command line here now this means
that
there is no issues as such with the test
cases
and everything is working fine as
expected over here in this one
so the assert equals is going to help
you to identify that if
the execution is proper and let's say
like if we put up some content like
some different content over here in this
asset equals
so i'm going to again execute this one
so that i will be able to see like if
you know what will happen that if this
message value and this value does not
matches like in normal situations it
will say like okay
uh the uh particular uh you know output
is going up and
there is no errors as such right so
let's see like what exactly uh it will
happen that if we
go for the executions like if we save
this file in such a way that we are
providing some wrong
inputs and what will happen to our asset
equal over here
so i'm going to again compile the file
here so again a new class file will be
available
and this time i'm going to execute this
class file again over here in this case
and the moment you did it the asset will
give you the
uh comparison over here saying that
there is a failure of the comparison
why there is a failure of the comparison
because according to the core base
it was expecting the value called simply
learn
but it simply got the value called
simply learn one two
which means that your test cases over
here got failed down
so this is the real way that how you
will be providing the comparison
like what you should be putting up to
the application and what kind of
response you should be getting in
in return of that so that's where you
will be able to provide a proper and a
complete
comparison here which will help you to
understand that what exactly output
you're going to get over here
and that's where the output will be
completely
available to you and you will be able to
get a proper output as such here
right so this is the way that how the
comparison will be performed and how you
will be able to see like these two
comparisons being done here
as such so this is the way that how
you're going to run the test cases in
the form
of the from the command line here so
that's it for
this topic thanks everyone
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here